MINUTES LATE IT IS THE ELEVATOR.
I MOVE FASTER THAN THE ELEVATOR --
SO GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE I'M
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND CALL THE
WEDNESDAY JUNE FIFTH.
MEETING OF THE RULES COMMITTEE
TO ORDER AND ASK MADAM SECRETARY
TO PLEASE ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
SENATORS BATES BATES HERE MINING
MINING HERE ROTH.
ROB HERE WILK PRESIDENT WILK
HERE ATKINS HERE ATKINS HERE WE
HAVE A QUORUM.
OKAY I I AM GONNA ENTERTAIN.
A CONSENT AGENDA BUT I'M GOING.
TO ASK FOR A MOTION ON I'M GONNA
SKIP ITEM TO FOR A MINUTE AND
TAKE THAT SEPARATE AS A AS AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT.
AGENDA AND THE ACTUALLY NO I
DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT RIGHT
MADAM OKAY.
SO I CAN TAKE ITEM TWO THREE
ITEM TWO IS THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE IS NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR.
ITEM THREE BILL REFERRALS ITEM
FOR SELECT COMMITTEE
APPOINTMENTS -- THAT IS SENATOR
UMBERG CHAIR OF A SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THE IMPACT OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE IN
CALIFORNIA APPOINTING SENATOR
CHIANG.
AS A MEMBER OF THAT COMMITTEE TO
FILL A VACANCY -- AND THEN ITEMS
FIVE THROUGH ELEVEN WITCHER
FLOOR AND KNOWLEDGE MINUTES.
HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN.
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL
THE ROLL.
SENATORS BATES.
BATES AYE MONNING.
MONNING AYE ROTH.
ROTH AYE WILK.
WILK AYE ATKINS HI HOW CAN SIGN
FIVE ZERO THANK YOU THAT IS FIVE
ZERO WE WILL GO RIGHT INTO THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR IN INVITE.
A DOCTOR MARK GAILY WHO IS THE
APPOINTEE FOR THE SECRETARY OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICE AGENCY TO COME FORWARD
[inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND DOCTOR IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE ANYONE YOU HAVE
BROUGHT WITH YOU.
ESPECIALLY THAT YOU WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT AND NOT.
THEN GO RIGHT INTO YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS IS STATEMENT AND THEN
WE WILL.
GO TO THE PANEL WELCOME RATE FOR
START THANK YOU -- SENATORS AND
PROGRAM FOR INVITING ME TODAY --
UNFORTUNATELY -- TODAY HAPPENS
TO BE THE LAST DAY OF SCHOOL FOR
THREE OF MY FOUR CHILDREN -- SO
I COULDN'T CONVINCE THEM. TO
COME UP BUT THEY'RE HERE WITH ME
IN IN SPIRIT ONE GRADUATED
YESTERDAY AND IS GOING TO READY
TO MIDDLE SCHOOL THERE THEY'RE
ALL YOUNG -- SO -- THEY'RE HERE
WITH ME IN SPIRIT BUT I KNOW
SOME OF OUR GREAT AGENCY STAFF
IS HERE TO SUPPORT ME AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
BE HERE I WANT TO START BY --
THINKING THE GOVERNOR FOR THIS
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY.
AND CHANCE TO REALLY IMPACT THE
LIVES OF SO MANY PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA THE DEPEND ON THE
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS A HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES.
I WANT TO THANK MY FAMILY MY
WONDERFUL WIFE AND AND GREAT
KIDS MOTHER BROTHER SISTER WHO
ARE HERE TODAY BUT I HAVE ALWAYS
BàN THAT -- IN AMAZING SUPPORT
AND GROUP OF PEOPLE TO GROUND ME.
IN THE MISSION AND THE WORK THAT
I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE TO DO I'M
HUMBLED IN THE FACE OF THIS
OPPORTUNITY -- EXCITED TO BOLDLY --
AND CONFIDENTLY WORK TO IMPROVE
THE LIVES CERTAIN THE LIFE
CHANCES OF THOSE WE HAVE A
CHANCE TO SERVE DAY IN AND DAY
OUT WITHIN THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE
OF DOING THAT AS A PHYSICIAN.
AS A PUBLIC HEALTH LEADER AS A
HEALTH SYSTEMS LEADER AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL BOTH IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND IN LOS ANGELES.
AND TO HAVE THIS TREMENDOUS
CHANCE TO HELP LEAD AND GUIDE
THE STATE ALONG WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LEGISLATURE ARE REALLY
JUST A TREMENDOUS HONOR.
AND I THINK THAT IT -- IT'S
ALWAYS AN EXCITING TIME TO BE IN
PUBLIC SERVICE I THINK THE THE
THE QUOTE SACRIFICES E WE HAVE
A CHANCE TO MAKE TO SERVE THOSE.
BAD ELECT YOU IN THAT I HAVE THE
HONOR OF BEING APPOINTED TO
SERVE TO REALLY THAT THERE'S NO
HIGHER HONOR IN MY MIND AND AS I
SPOKE TO SOME OF YOU -- IT'S
ALSO JUST A GREAT DEAL OF FUN TO
BE ABLE TO SEE HOW THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
IMPLEMENTING CAN IMPACT AND
CHANGE PEOPLE'S LIVES -- SO WITH
THAT I REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
TODAY'S CONVERSATION -- AND
REALLY YEAR MANSI HERE'S A COM
WHERE WE CAN COMPLETE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND REALLY MAKE
MEANINGFUL AND COULD CHANGE --
FOR PEOPLE WHO DEPEND ON OUR
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
MODDING WANT WE START IN YOUR
DIRECTION.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND DOCTOR LET ME
OFFER MY CONGRATULATIONS AS WELL
ON THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT
AND CONFIDENCE IN YOU.
SHOULD IT OUR CHANCE TO TALK
BRIEFLY THIS MORNING AND GET
BETTER ACQUAINTED.
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN YEAR.
PAST HISTORY NOT ONLY
ADMINISTERING SOME LARGE
ORGANIZATIONS BUT IS A
PEDIATRICIAN.
TUNE INTO THE NEEDS OF CHILDREN
IN OUR STATE IN.
SOME OVER MAYBE FUTURE
PRIORITIZATION BUT LET ME START
WITH THE QUESTION JUST ABOUT
THIS SCALE THE SCOPE THE SIZE OF
THIS AGENCY MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS
OVER THIRTY THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
WHAT'S YOUR ADMINISTRATIVE
VISION BEFORE WE GET TO YEAR
MAYBE.
PUBLIC HEALTH AND COMMUNITY
HEALTH STATE HEALTH.
HOW DO YOU MOVE INTO AN
ORGANIZATION LIKE THAT IN
DEVELOP?
SYSTEMS THAT MIGHT.
SOME MIGHT RESIST WHO WERE.
ARE STUCK IN OLD HABITS AND OLD
WAYS.
SURE THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION --
YOU ARE RIGHT THIS IS A
TREMENDOUS IN LARGE ORGANIZATION
WITH A VERY DIVERSE MISSION.
EVERYTHING FROM HEALTH CARE DAY
HUMAN SERVICES -- TO REALLY
MANAGING A NORMA SITE T.
PROJECTS SO THERE'S A LOT OF
CULTURAL CORRALLING THAT IS
NECESSARY -- HAVING HAD A CHANCE
TO DO AT A DIFFERENT SCALE BUT
STILL A LARGE SCALE IN LOS
ANGELES.
REALLY I THINK WHAT I'VE LEARNED
IS LEADERSHIP MATTERS A GREAT
DEAL -- AND BEING ABLE TO
CLEARLY ARTICULATE A VISION.
OF WHERE WE WANT TO GO AND
REALLY UNDERSTANDING THE HISTORY
OF HOW WE GOT TO THE CERTAIN
MOMENT ARE THINGS THAT I PLAN TO
DO WHEN HAVE EXPERIENCE DOING.
AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS -- USING
EVERY OPPORTUNITY WHETHER IT'S
YOUR DIRECTORS MEDIAN OR AN
EMAIL TO ALL STAFF TO REALLY
CONSISTENTLY BEAT THE DRUM OF A
VISION OF COLLABORATION
PARTNERSHIP USING OUR ASSETS
BOTH PEOPLE DATA.
PHYSICAL ASSETS DODD FOR
FINANCIAL ASSETS TO REALLY MOVE
IN A SPECIFIC DIRECTION TO LIFT
UP ALL BOATS AND IT DOESN'T TO
START WITH WHAT I SAY -- IT
STARTS WITH WHAT AGENCY
LEADERSHIP DOES AND THEN THE
DEPARTMENT HEADS.
AND IDENTIFYING LEADERS ABOUT
SUPPORTING OUR EXISTING LEADERS
AND IDENTIFYING NEW LEADERS IN
VACANT POSITIONS WHERE WE CAN
REALLY TRUST THE THERE ARE WELL
ALIGNED.
WITH THAT GOAL AND VISION AND
CREATING AS MANY VENUES AS
POSSIBLE THERE'S A LOT THAT'S
GREAT THAT'S ALREADY HAPPENING --
WITHIN THE AGENCY THAT CREATES
CROSS DEPARTMENT COLLABORATION
AND I WANT TO FIND AND IDENTIFY
MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO DO THAT
WHETHER IT'S ON THE ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS OR I'LL BREAK
PREVENTION OR THE YOU KNOW A
NUMBER OF OTHER ISSUES THAT
REALLY FALL IN THE BELLY WORK OF
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN.
SERVICES AGENCY I SEE TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO DO MORE AND MORE
OF THAT AS WE GO EIGHT IN IN YOU
CITED SOME OF THE CHALLENGES WE
TALK SOME ABOUT -- HABSI
OUTBREAKS THE THE FEVER --
UNFORTUNATELY ESTABLISHED IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BUT NOW GROWING
PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT IN THE
SALINAS VALLEY -- YOU TOUCHED ON
HOMELESSNESS. ONE OF THE THINGS
YOU TALKED ABOUT IN OUR
CONVERSATION WAS.
HOW YOU COORDINATE WITH COUNTY?
DEPARTMENTS IN THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY SO KINDA ZEROING IN ON
THAT PUBLIC HEALTH MISSION.
HOW DO YOU SEEN A YEAR
LEADERSHIP -- HELPING US BETTER
ANA ADDRESS SOME OF THESE PUBLIC
HEALTH THREATS.
SHE SURE THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION OUR AS WE SPOKE ABOUT
THIS MORNING SO MANY THINGS IN
THE PUBLIC HEALTH ROUND DON'T
KNOW A BOUNDARY.
THEY DON'T FOLLOW THE COUNTY
BORDER THEY DON'T FOLLOW THE
CITY BORDER.
THEY EXTEND AND SO THE STATE HAS
A VERY IMPORTANT ROLE -- IN
WORKING WITH LOCAL COUNTY
LEADERSHIP AND THE PUBLIC HEALTH
ARENA TO ENSURE THAT THE ISSUES
AT THE LOCAL LEVELARE MANAGED
AS WELL AND COME PROPERLY AS
POSSIBLE.
THAT MEANS THAT BOTH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE RESOURCE SUPPORT AND
REALLY BEING A TOP PARTNER FOR
EXAMPLE -- WHEN DO WE DECLARE A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY OR WHAT
ARE THE STEPS THAT DEFINE THE
DECLARATION OF A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY?
AND THEN ENSURING THAT AS WE
ACCOUNT FOR ONE HOW THINGS WE
KNOW HOW DISEASES SPREAD AN
OUTBREAK SPREAD BEING ABLE TO
WORK WITH COUNTY IS WHO ARE KIND
OF AT THE NEXT LINE OF CONCERN.
SO THAT WERE AS PREPARED AS
POSSIBLE SO I THINK IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE THAT THE STATE
CAN PLAY AN PARTNERING WITH THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. TO
MEET THAT LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
NEED BUT THEN THIS BROADER STATE
NEED AS WELL.
THANK YOU AND I KNOW OTHERS HAVE
QUESTIONS TO OF THIS CLOSE WITH
THE QUESTION IT GOES BACK TO
CHILDREN IN PUBLIC HEALTH WE
TALK SOME ABOUT -- CHALLENGES OF
WHAT'S BEEN DESCRIBED AS A
PUBLIC HEALTH EPIDEMIC OF YOU SO
BE CITY PREVENTABLE DIABETES --
HAD A WE IS A STATE GET IN FRONT
OF THAT AS AS OPPOSED TO USING
OUR LIMITED RESOURCES TO
TREATING ILLNESS AND DISEASE.
HAD A WE GET TO THE FRONT END OF
PROMOTING HEALTH AND PREVENTION.
SURE I THINK EIGHT EIGHT IF WE
DEPEND ON THE PHYSICIANS AND
CLINICIANS TO DO THAT WORK IT'S
TOO LATE WE NEED TO HAVE THIS BE
A COMMUNITY FOCUSED INITIATIVE.
DIED IN EXERCISE WE NOW ARE TWO
VERY KEY COMPONENTS -- WE HAVE
TO SUPPORT COMMUNITIES WHERE
THERE MIGHT NOT BE GREAT ACCESS
TO EXERCISE SCHOOL LUNCH
PROGRAMS HEALTHY FOOD OPTIONS
ALL THE THINGS THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN DOING.
BUT I THINK -- AS WE SORT OF
ENTER THE NEW FRONTIER BE MORE
AGGRESSIVE OVER -- SOME OF THE
CONTRIBUTORS WHETHER THAT'S THE
SORT OF SWEETENED BEVERAGE
INDUSTRY OR WHETHER THAT THE
PENAL ON HEALTHY FOODS THAT SO
MANY COMMUNITIES HAVE EASIER
ACCESS TO THAN HEALTHY FOODS.
THERE'S A VERY MEANINGFUL ROLE
WE HAVE TO PLAY AGAIN SUPPORTING
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO
IMPLEMENT MONITORING AND
SURVEILLANCE OF WHERE WE CAN
MAKE A DIFFERENCE ON THE DISH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND AGAIN I JUST
WANT TO CONGRATULATE YOU IN
THANK YOU FOR STEPPING UP.
TO HELP LEADER STATE IN THESE
VERY IMPORTANT ARENAS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR MINING IS SENATOR BATES
THANK YOU OF AND LET ME ADD TO
AYE ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
GOOD SENATOR ON TO MY LEFT.
YOU HAVE AN AMAZING RESUME AND I
WAS LOOKING AT THINKING AND YOU
WANT TO DO THIS JOB SO.
WE KNOW WITHOUT DOUBT CERTAINLY
HAS -- PROBABLY A COMMITMENT TO
THE PASSION THAT YOU HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT THE PEOPLE OF OUR
STATE HAVE.
A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR GOOD
HEALTH AND JOB CERTAINLY A GOOD
FUTURE BECAUSE OF THAT.
I'VE BEEN VERY INVOLVED IN THE
SILVER A LIVING HOME ISSUE IN
THE OPIOID CRISIS SPECIFICALLY
BECAUSE IN MY DISTRICT WHICH IS
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY AND NORTH
SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
A LOT OF FUN YOUNG PEOPLE DYING
HA FROM OUTSOLE I AM INTERESTED
IN HEARING IF YOU HAVE SOME
IDEAS ABOUT HOW WE CAN APPROACH.
THE SOBER LIVING HOME ISSUE OF
CERTAINLY THE FEDERAL ISSUES
KIND OF OVERLAY BEING ABLE TO
GET MORE OVERSIGHT NOT FULL
MATCH THE REGULATORY.
FIBER OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE MEETING THE PROMISES
THAT THEY MAKE AND I YOU HAD --
LOT OF EXPERIENCE I BELIEVE
READING YOUR RESUME IN LA.
WITH THIS COULD YOU SHARE SOME
IDEAS ON HOW WE HAVE FORMED A
TASK FORCES A SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT TASK FORCE AND WE WILL
LOOK FORWARD.
TO PERHAPS YOU VISITING US FOR
THE TIME TO SHARE SOME OF YOUR
THOUGHTS ON RESOURCES WE MIGHT
REACH OUT TO THAT MAYBE A FEW
MINUTES TO GIVE ME SOME IDEAS ON
ALL OF THAT BECAUSE IT'S DRIVING
IS YOU KNOW IN OUR COMMUNITIES
HOMELESS.
THE SUICIDE AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE
ALL OF THAT IS KINDA WRAPPED
TOGETHER IN A MAJOR PROBLEM OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE FACING.
SO AGAIN FIRST THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION AND THE INVITATION I
WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO JOINING
YOU IN WHATEVER VENUE MAKES
SENSE TO SHARE THOUGHTS AND AND
REALLY DIALOGUE ABOUT THE ISSUE
BECAUSE IT'S A COMPLICATED.
ONE IT'S AN EMERGING -- ONE AT
THE SAME TIME WE'RE GRAPPLING
WITH THIS SORT OF GROWTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
CHALLENGES IN COMMUNITIES
WHETHER IT'S OPIATES ARE MAPPED
OR OTHER.
OTHER -- DRUGS ARE ADDICTIVE IN
EASILY ABUSED -- AND THEN YOU
HAVE THIS INTERESTING
OPPORTUNITY OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS OF ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
FOCUS ON IT WHETHER IT'S AROUND
THE OPIATE SPECIFICALLY FOR DRUG
MEDI CAL FOR EXAMPLE BROADLY
SPEAKING.
AND IT CREATES THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO BRING NOT SO MUCH MORE
REGULATION AS MUCH AS AN
EXPECTATION AND A SET OF QUALITY
MEASURES THAT HELPS DEFINE A
GROWING INDUSTRY WHAT WE'VE
MOVED AWAY.
WHAT WE'RE MOVING AWAY FROM IS A
SOLUTION YOU ORGANIZED A YOU
KNOW HODGEPODGE TO THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE -- IN SOME
WAYS A NETWORK THAT HS A
CERTAIN STANDARD EXPECTATIONS
THAT PEOPLE WHO LIVE NEAR THESE
HOMES CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT IT
MEANS WHO PEOPLE WHO SEND THEIR
LOVE ONES -- TO WON THE SETTINGS
CAN REALLY HAVE AN EXPECTATION
AS TO WHAT THAT PERSON IS GOING
TO RECEIVE WE'RE A WAYS AWAY
FROM THAT CERTAINLY STATEWIDE
THERE'S POCKETS OF THE STATE
THAT ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS THAT
CHALLENGE LA IS ONE OF THEM SO
I'M FAMILIAR WITH THAT.
BUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THAT
BROADLY SPREAD AND SOME OF THE
ARTICLES I KNOW WE ALL TRACK
CONSTITUENTS TO COME AND SHARE
WITH YOU THE SAD STORIES OF LOVE
ONES WHO WERE.
PUT IN THESE PLACES EXPECTING TO
HAVE GOOD OUTCOMES AND THEN WE
OF TRAGEDY AT THE END OF THE DAY
THERE ARE SOLUTIONS TO THAT THAT
START WITH.
HAVING SOME EXPECTATIONS QUALITY
MEASURES AND THEN SOME
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY LOOK IF YOU
MEET THESE THE FUNDING WILL BE
THERE TO SUPPORT YOU IN THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU FOR THEIR RESPONSE YOU
WILL SEE ME OR HEAR FROM ME I'LL
FREQUENTLY.
AS WE WRESTLE WITH THIS BECAUSE
I KNOW IT TO ME AT THE COMMON
DENOMINATOR OF A LOT OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH FIVE PROBLEMS THAT
WE'RE FACING IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
TRULY A FULL THANK YOU DOCTOR
AND YOU WILL HAVE MY SUPPORT
THANK YOU I LOOK FORWARD TO
FUTURE CONVERSATIONS.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES.
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU PRO TEM.
WHERE TO START?
SO I WANTED TO ASK YOU ABOUT
PAGE EIGHTEEN OF THE LA COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES AUDIT.
ALL I MEMORIZED PAGE SEVENTEEN
YEAH I KNOW I DIDN'T GET TO
EIGHTEEN I'M SORRY REALLY I'M
ONLY KIDDING ANYWAY SO WE SO WE
SO WE DISCUSS THE ISSUE AND I
AND A YOU WANT YEAH I KNOW YOU
WALKED OFF WITH A COPY SO.
BASICALLY I HAD TO CONSTITUENTS
OF ONE THAT WAS MURDERED BECAUSE
NOW IT'S THE CORSETED DEMAND
OTHER ONES ALLEGEDLY MURDERED A
TEN YEAR OLD BOY AN EIGHT YEAR
OLD BOY.
SHOULD AND PULLED OUT A HOPE OF
HOME ALONE A LONG TIME AGO THEIR
THEIR THEIR TRAGIC STORIES --
MEETING WITH THE AUDITOR
RECENTLY AFTER THE REPORT CAME
OUT.
THE ONE QUICK THERE'S NOTHING WE
DO LEGISLATIVELY SO WAS ALL KIND
OF LIKE SYSTEMATIC.
ANSWER THE QUESTION I HAD FOR
HER WAS IS LA COUNTY AND OUT
LIAR THAT THEY'RE JUST SO LARGE
AND UNWIELDY OR DO YOU THINK
THIS A PROBLEM EVERYWHERE AND
HER ANSWER IS SHE DID KNOW SO.
JUST.
IT'S ABOUT YOUR THOUGHTS IN LA
COUNTY WAIT WHETHER YOU THINK
IT'S A SYSTEMIC PROBLEM ACROSS
THE STATE AND AND WHAT.
DO YOU PLAN TO DO ABOUT IT IF IN
FACT IT IS A PROBLEM STATEWIDE.
YEAH THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION --
SO.
I KNOW YOU TO VOTE BY RESUMES IN
BACKGROUND BUT I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING AS A
PEDIATRICIAN IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM -- INFORMALLY IN SAN
FRANCISCO IS A COMMUNITY
PEDIATRICIAN TAKING CARE PLENTY
OF THE KIDS IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM BUT MORE
FORMALLY IN LOS ANGELES -- AS
PART OF A CLINIC SYSTEM THAT
TAKES CARE OF SPECIFICALLY KIDS
IN.
FOSTER CARE.
AND I THINK UNFORTUNATELY IT IS --
IT'S LIKELY A SYSTEMIC PROBLEM.
HI I WANT TO START BY SAYING
THAT.
THE WORK OF CHILD WELFARE
DEPARTMENTS THE SOCIAL WORKERS --
IT IS HARD WORK IT IS -- THERE
ARE THERE CHALLENGING STORIES
SOMETIMES THE STAFF DON'T HAVE
ALL OF THE SUPPORT AND UP TO
DATE TRAINING THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO PICK.
PICK UP EVERY ISSUE THAT A CHILD
MIGHT BE FACING I THINK THEY
OFTEN WORKING CONDITIONS WHERE
KIDS ARE MOVED AROUND WE TALK IN
THE DOCTOR IN THE MEDICINE WORLD
ABOUT CONTINUITY -- WE DON'T.
SORT OF VALUE OR EMPHASIZED
CONTINUITY IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM NEARLY ENOUGH.
SINGLE KID WILL MAYBE HAVE THREE
OR FOUR DIFFERENT SOCIAL WORKERS
IN THE COURSE OF THE YEAR AND
THAT IN ITSELF ALLOWS YOU TO
DROP THE BALL SO THERE ARE IN
THE SYSTEM MANY OPPORTUNITIES.
TO DROPPING ISSUE AND IT'S REAL
PROBLEM AND I THINK IT COMES
AROUND OUR SYSTEMSTHAT.
AND THESE THESE ARE PROGRAMS ARE
BASED ON WHETHER THOSE OF THE I.
T. SYSTEMS OR THE TRAINING
PROGRAMS AND THEN IT ALSO COMES
DOWN TO SUPERVISION -- I KNOW
THAT THE REPORT YOU SHARED WITH
ME AND IT'S NOT A SURPRISE TO ME
THAT EVEN WHEN THE CASE CARRYING
THE CASELOADS OF THE INDIVIDUAL --
SOCIAL WORKERS ARE ADEQUATE
SOMETIMES THEY DON'T HAVE THE
SUPPORT BECAUSE SUPERVISORS ARE
SPREAD TOO THING SO I THINK
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THINGS AND
WE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND OUR CHILD WELFARE
BRANCH.
CAN DO TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE COMPANIES TO ENSURE THAT
SOME OF THE VERY CLEAR AREAS OF
CONCERN ARE SHORED UP SO THAT WE
CAN AT LEAST SAID EVERYBODY UP
FOR THE OPTIMAL SUCCESS AND I
THINK THE AUDIT.
REFLECTS THAT AND MY SUSPICION
IS THAT THESE ARE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WOULD SERVE
THE ENTIRE STATE FAIRLY WELL.
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU DOCTOR --
FOLLOW QUESTION -- I KNOW YOU
KNOW THIS BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN ON
THE FRONTLINE IN TERMSOF THE
THE DATA ON FIVE FOSTER YOUTH.
ONLY ONLY 4% -- GO ON TO
GRADUATE AND GET A GET A BA AND
TOO MANY ARE HOMELESS AND TOO
MANY OR ARE INCARCERATED.
AND AND COURSE IN IN MY CASE I
KNOW YOU KNOW THIS BEING FROM LA
COUNTY ONE OUT OF EVERY THREE
FOSTER YOUTH IS IN I IN MY
DISTRICT.
SO JUST CURIOUS YOUR YOUR
THOUGHTS IN THE PROGRAM AND
MAYBE A VISION MOVING FORWARD
THAT CAN HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT.
ON ON THIS COMMUNITY THAT THE
NEEDS ALL THE HELP THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE THEM.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE THERE ARE SO
MANY OPPORTUNITIES I THINK COULD
OFTEN BECAUSE CHILD WELFARE
DEPART.
DEPARTMENTS HAVE REALLY TWO
RELATED BUT DISTINCT MISSIONS
CHILD PROTECTION AND THEN
ENSURING KIDS IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM THRIVE -- AND AS WE THINK
ABOUT THE SECOND GROUP RIGHT
KIDS WHO ARE.
IN FOSTER CARE OUT OF HOME
PLACEMENT I THINK THERE'S A LOT
OF OPPORTUNITIES TO SUPPORT A
MORE NORMALIZED CHILDHOOD -- THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SURE THE
KIDS GET A CHANCE TO BE IN CHOIR
CODED DANCER BEYOND THAT SPORTS
TEAM WE SOMETIMES OVERLOOK THAT
CHANCE TO MAKE THAT CONNECTION.
BECAUSE WERE SO OVERWHELMED WITH
TEST SOME OF THE OTHER BREAD AN
BUTTER ISSUES I WOULD LOVE TO
SEE US MOVE TOWARDS.
THAT -- SUCCESS NOT JUST HEY DID
WE GET THEM SAFELY TO EIGHTEEN
OR TWENTY FOUR BUTWHAT DID IT
LOOK LIKE FOR THEM IN WHERE
WHERE THE OPPORTUNITIES BECAUSE
WE ALL KNOW THE STORY.
OF THE CHILD IN IN THE SYSTEM
WHO MEETS THAT CULTURE THAT
CHOIR INSTRUCTOR WHO REALLY
PULLS A MOP AND SUPPORTS THEM.
AND SO THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO
FULFILL THAT VISION I THINK A
LITTLE BIT MORE HOLISTICALLY
THEM WE HAVE IS A SYSTEM AND I
HOPE TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT.
THE DEPARTMENT TO EXPLORE WAYS
TO DO THAT.
LIKE A LIKE A FOSTER YOUTH GRANT
FOR EXTRA CURRICULAR ACTIVITIES
YOU THINK THAT'S A GOOD IDEA.
I'VE HEARD SOMEONE -- PICKS THAT
IDEA AND I I THINK IT'S AN
EXCELLENT.
ONE ALL RIGHT.
I PROMISE I'LL TAKE IT AS AN
ENDORSEMENT.
ON THE WAY REALLY REALLY ENJOYED
OUR TIME TOGETHER AND YOU'VE GOT
A BIG CHALLENGE BUT I KNOW I
KNOW THAT YOU'RE UP TO THE TASK
AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD -- TO
VOTING TO CONFIRM THE TODAY
THANK YOU DOCTOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR CENTER ROTH
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM.
MISTER SECRETARY CONGRATULATIONS
EXTRAORDINARILY WELL QUALIFIED
AND FRANKLY WE'RE LUCKY TO HAVE
YOU.
I DON'T THINK I HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I THINK MY COLLEAGUES
OF COVER THE AREA I WOULD --
WHAT ASK THIS AS YOU CONTINUE TO
SETTLE AND I'D ASK YOU TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THE -- MAN I'VE ASKED
THIS OF OTHER.
A KAFFIR MAYES AYE AYE I'D ASK
YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
NINETEEN NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT.
FUNDING ALLOCATION FORMULA FOR
MENTAL HEALTH IN PARTICULAR.
AND IN PARTICULAR AS IT PERTAINS
TO THE UNDER EQUITY COUNTIES.
INCLUDING THOSE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA LIKE RIVERSIDE.
AND SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY.
WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS NEED DOWN
THERE FOR MENTAL HEALTH.
SERVICES RELATED SERVICES AND WE
SIMPLY NEED TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO FIND MORE RESOURCES TO TAKE
CARE OF THE ISSUE.
I AM CONFIDENT THAT YOU'LL DO SO
CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN I WOULD BE
DELIGHTED TO MOVE YOUR
CONFIRMATION AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
[inaudible]
THANK YOU -- SENATOR ROTH -- I
YEAH I WANT TO SAY HOW MUCH I
APPRECIATE THE TIME YOU SPENT
WITH ME AND AND SOME MEMBERS OF
MY STAFF YESTERDAY -- I THINK
IT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE.
FOR A CONFIRMATION HEARING.
ODD TO GET INTO.
AS OUR SENATOR MINING SAID.
THE EXTENT OF WHAT THIS POSITION
I IS AN MEANS. FOR US HERE AT
THE STATE IT'S A HUGE
APPOINTMENT IT'S CLEARLY FOR
MANY OF US ONE OF THE MOST
pIMPORTANT BECAUSE IT TOUCHES SO
MANY ASPECTS.
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS OF PEOPLE
VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN THE STATE.
AND WHETHER WE'RE TALKIN -- THE
OPIOID CRISIS OR PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISES LIKE HAVE A AND YET ANY
NUMBER OF VALLEY FEVER.
WHICH WE'VE BECOME MORE AND MORE --
ENGAGED IN AN AWARE OF ALL THE
WAY TO OUR YOU KNOW INTEGRATION
OF HOUSING AND HEALTH CARE WHICH
I OBVIOUSLY THINK IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT.
PIECE OF SOLVING THE PROBLEM AND
WHAT YOU'VE DONE IN LOS ANGELES
AND SAN FRANCISCO -- I THINK THE
BIGGEST -- IT'D TO APPRECIATE
THE EXTENT OF WHAT YOU ARE.
GETTING READY TO ENGAGE IN -- I
JUST HOPE BECAUSE WE SPENT A
VERY LONG TIME YESTERDAY MORE
THAN MY SCHEDULER WAS HAPPY WITH.
REALLY BECAUSE THESE ISSUES ARE
SO CRITICAL AND THERE IS A ROOM
FULL OF PEOPLE HERE.
THAT I SEE THAT TOUCH ALL OF
THOSE ISSUES AND OBVIOUSLY THIS
IS ONE OF THE MOST CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT APPOINTMENTS -- THAT
THE GOVERNOR IS GOING TO MAKE
OUR BECAUSE IT IMPACTS SO MUCH
OF OUR LIVES SO I APPRECIATE THE
EXTENT -- THE ISSUES OF OUR HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO INTEGRATE SO
MANY OF THESE THINGS.
OUT WE'VE GOT SO MANY THINGS ON
OUR PLATE RIGHT NOW WE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT YESTERDAY ABOUT
DEVOUT DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
AND THE RATE.
STRUCTURE I MEAN THESE ARE ALL
THE GOALS AND CHALLENGES WE HAVE
AND I THINK MOSTLY ON BEHALF OF
MY COLLEAGUES -- WE ARE JUST
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN HAVE AN ON
GOING.
DIRECT SERIOUS DIALOGUE ABOUT
THESE CHALLENGES AND HOW WE'RE
GONNA TOGETHER APPROACH.
THESE THINGS THE COST OF HEALTH
CARE HOW ARE WE GOING TO WORK
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS THAT --
THERE ARE MANY STAKEHOLDERS HERE
IN THE ROOM AND WE ARE ALL BUSY
DOING IT ON BEHALF OF A
POPULATION OF PEOPLE.
THAT COULDN'T BE HERE EVEN IF
THEY WANTED TO BE SO -- I COULD
BRING UP TO TWENTY ISSUES AGAIN
JUST.
FOR YOU NOW. TO PUT IT ON THE
RECORD BUT I THINK ALL THESE
PEOPLE KNOW AND THE QUESTIONS MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ASK OUR CRITICAL
SO.
I WILL GO TO THE PUBLIC BECAUSE
OUR I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
APPOINTMENT -- I'M EXCITED ABOUT
THE POSSIBILITIES.
AND AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME I
WILL FOLLOW MY COLLEAGUE IN
SUPPORT BUT RIGHT NOW.
I THINK WE WANT TO HEAR FROM
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND
WELCOME.
AND I WILL ASK.
YOU TO GET YOU STATE YOUR NAME
WHO YOU REPRESENT.
AND I WILL BEG FOR BREVITY HI.
IN THE INTEREST OF OUR SOME MORE
WONDERFUL APPOINTEES WHO ARE ARE
WAITING BUT ALSO BECAUSE I KNOW
WE WE ALL HAVE STUFF TO DO.
LET'S START WITH YOU MISS COMPEL
BETH CAPELL OVER SUPPORT THIS IS
FOR SUPPORTS BETH CAPELL ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA PLEASED TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS NOMINATION.
AND HAPPY TO SAY THAT WE'VE
ALREADY BEGUN WORKING WITH THE
SECRETARY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HIM FOR MANY YEARS
TO COME.
ON GETTING TWO GOALS THAT I KNOW
WE SHARE WITH MANY OF THIS
COMMITTEE MAKING SURE THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIAN HAS HELPED QUALITY
AFFORDABLE HEALTHCARE.
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
IN THE WE'D START TO ADDRESS
HEALTH CARE COSTS WHILE
IMPROVING QUALITY AND REDUCING
HEALTH DISPARITIES THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM FOR TEN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS CHRISTINE ABBAS HAMILTON I'M
WITH YOU W. APPS ME LOCAL THIRTY
NINE THIRTY WE REPRESENT.
HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND I JUST
AS WORKERS -- AS WE ARE ALL
FAMILIAR THERE ARE OVER HALF A
MILLION PEOPLE AND I HSS OUR
SENIORS AND PEOPLE DISABILITIES
AND THAT'S THE WORLD THAT I LIVE
IN AND SO WE'RE THRILLED. TO
HAVE -- THE ABILITY TO WORK WITH
YOU ON SOME MAJOR INNOVATIONS IN
THAT IN THAT SPACE IT'S LONG DO.
SO WERE EAGER TO GET STARTED
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE TALKED ABOUT
THAT YESTERDAY.
TOO WELCOME.
THANK YOU JAMES NORMAN ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION REPRESENT OVER FORTY
FOUR OR FORTY FIVE SORRY.
THOUSAND PHYSICIANS STATEWIDE
WE'VE ALREADY BEEN WORKING ON
TOGETHER WITH THE SECRETARY WE
REALLY APPRECIATE HIS ACCEPTANCE
OF THIS GREAT RESPONSIBILITY
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM PRO TEM AND MEMBERS MARK
WINDOWS WITH US YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA -- ON BEHALF OF OUR
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
APPOINTMENT OF MR GARY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MY CAROL WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY BUT WE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH DOCTOR
GAILY WE'RE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
WORKING WITH HIM.
AS YOU KNOW WE WORK ON A WHOLE
HOST OF ISSUE AREAS EVERYTHING
FROM HOMELESSNESS TO HAVE MEDI
CAL TO AT SOCIETY CAL WORKS SO
WE'RE GOING TO BE WORKING WITH
THEM A LOT AND REALLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO IT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF
OF THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORM REPRESENTING THE
THIRTY SIX DISTRICT HOSPITALS
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE BEEN DOING.
AND ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE WHOSE MISSION IT IS TO
ADVANCE SOUND PUBLIC POLICY AND
INSPIRE LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUES
OF BRAIN HEALTH.
I AM HONORED TO HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS OUR VERY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS
APPOINTMENT DR MARK -- GALLEY
WHEN YOU SAY YOUR NAME FOR THE
RECORD MAGGIE MERIT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BETSEY ARMSTRONG ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
AND WE'VE ACTUALLY HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
SECRETARY KELLY IN HIS BRIEF
TENURE IN A REALLY HAPPY WITH
THE WORK THAT HE'S DONE WITH US
AND REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HIM AND HIS TEAM AT
THE AGENCY AND ENDORSES
NOMINATION THINKING.
THANK YOU THE AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS HOST IF YOU NOT I
MEAN IT'S WITH CHILDREN NOW.
HOUSE SIXTEEN AT I. B. DOES NOT
CENTER WITH CHILDREN NOW.
WE WORK ON CHILDREN'S ISSUES --
HEALTHCARE EDUCATION AND CHILD
WELFARE A PRENATAL TWENTY SIX
AND WE'RE REALLY EXCITED AT AND
PROUD TO SUPPORT DOCTOR GODLY --
WE WELCOME HIS LEADERSHIP TO
FACILITATE IN MAKING THE BALL
CHANGES NEEDED TO BETTER SERVE
CHILDREN.
IN MEDI CAL AND OTHER HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICE PROGRAMS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HIM.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M FERRE MCDADE TING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES WERE VERY EXCITED.
ABOUT DR KELLY THE COMING ON
BOARD AS SECRETARY STRONGLY
SUPPORT HIM AND WANT TO NOTE
THAT HIS DEEP COUNTY EXPERIENCE
I THINK WILL BE AN ASSET THAT
THE SECRETARY LEVEL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
COMMENSURATE FRANK MECCA THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
OUR MEMBERS ADMINISTER.
MUCH OF THE HUMAN SERVICES SIDE
OF THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY PROGRAMS WERE EXTREMELY
EXCITED AND AND HAPPY TO ENDORSE.
THIS NOMINATION -- ESPECIALLY
GIVEN OUR EXPERIENCE WITH DOCTOR
GALLEY AND IS REALLY UNIQUE
APPRECIATION FOR AND COMMITMENT
TO THE INTER CONNECTEDNESS.
BETWEEN HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES SO THAT WE COULD
PROVIDE WHOLE FAMILY CARE AND SO
WE'RE REALLY -- EXCITED IN HER
JUROR -- CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU.
MADAM PRO TEM AND MEMBERS BARBER
GLAZER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OVER FOUR HUNDRED
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SSTEMS I'M
PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF DOCTOR GALLEYS
CONFIRMATION.
AS A AS A POSITION AND DAY A
COUNTY LEADER HE IS UNIQUELY
QUALIFIED FOR THIS POSITION.
CH A LOOKS FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU AS WE ALL MOVE FORWARD --
TO TO PROVIDE EXPANDING HEALTH
CARE AND ACCESS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MADAM HER TEN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JEAN HEARST HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS CALIFORNIA'S
TWENTY EIGHT HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OF DOCTOR GALLEYS APPOINTMENT
TODAY -- WE SHARE THE ENTHUSIASM
OF MY COLLEAGUES ON HIS
APPOINTMENT AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HIM THANKS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS -- RICK
ROLLINS REPRESENT HARKIS SO
SHE'S IN A REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES I'M ALSO A PARENT OF A
TWENTY YEAR OLD SON WITH AUTISM
WHO -- RECEIVES SO MANY OF THE
SERVICES THAT YOUR DEPARTMENT OF
PROVIDE. TO FOLKS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE'RE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF A DOCTOR COLLEAGUES
CONFIRMATION AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH HIM IN THE
FUTURE.
THANK YOU AND FORMER SECTOR THE
SENATE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MAYOR MARTIN HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL CESSATION
REPRESENTING THE STATE'S EIGHT
NONPROFIT FREESTANDING
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF DR KELLY'S
APPOINTMENT.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS LINDA TO
NARROW IT TO THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK WE'D LIKE
TO WONDER SUPPORT FOR DOCTOR
COLLEAGUES CONFIRMATION AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER
ON ISSUES OF HEALTH EQUITY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON BREANNA PITTMAN
SPENCER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF DR DALLAS NOMINATION.
I KNOW THAT WE STARTED SOME
CONVERSATIONS AND CONTINUE TO
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
THANK YOU.
ALISON RAINY ON BEHALF OF MOLINA
HEALTH CARE HERE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE NOMINATION OF
DOCTOR GALLEY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TERESA START WITH
KAISER PERMANENTE A ALSO HERE IN
SUPPORT OF DR KELLY'S NOMINATION
OF HAD THE GOOD FORTUNE OF
PARTNERING WITH HIM ALREADY --
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT CONTINUED
RELATIONSHIP AND I WANT TO ECHO
SENATOR LOTT'S COMMENTS WERE
VERY LUCKY TO HAVE YOU SO THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MEGAN SUPERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES
THE PART CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION WHICH IS THE
REPRESENTS OVER THIRTEEN HUNDRED
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA WE SERVE ABOUT ONE
THIRD OF MEDIC OF PRIMARY CARE
MEDI CAL PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA
WE ARE VERY MUCH.
EXCITED ABOUT THIS APPOINTMENT
AND SUPPORT HIS CONFIRMATION
TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
SENATORS BATES ALL RIGHT BATES
AYE MONNING.
MONNING AYE ROTH ROUGH I WILL.
WILK AYE ATKINS HI [inaudible]
CONGRATULATIONS UNANIMOUS
.
AS SOME OF OUR GUESTS ARE
DEPARTING LET ME I INVITE. THREE
INDIVIDUALS UP WHO ARE.
BEING APPOINTED TODAY ARE ALL
HAVE BEEN APPOINTED BEING
CONFIRMED TODAY. FOR THE OF FAIR
HOUSING.
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
COUNCIL [inaudible]
THERE.
DALE BRODSKY MICHAEL TIM A
GLACIS AND THEY ARE A SURE -- WE
WELCOME YOU HERE TODAY WHY DON'T
I START ON WITH YOU -- MS
BRODSKY AND ASK IF YOU WANT TO
INTRODUCE ANYBODY -- AND THEN
MAKE SOME COMMENTS AND WE'LL GO
DOWN THE LINE.
THANK YOU AND WELCOME.
IS JUST MAKE SURE TALK -- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD AFTERNOON --
I AM HUMBLED AND HONORED. TO BE.
BEFORE YOU TODAY -- WITHOUT
DWELLINGON THE PAST IN A
SENTIMENTAL WAY BEING HERE TODAY.
SHOWS HOW LIFE AT ITS BEST CAN
COME FULL CIRCLE -- FROM
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT TO
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE I SERVED
AS A LEGAL COUNSEL TO THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT.
PRACTICES COMMISSION THAT'S WHAT
IT WAS CALLED OUT IS THE
PREDECESSOR AGENCY TO THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING COUNCIL.
AND THEN I IT DOES THAT THREE
YEARS WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING THIS WAS
AS A NEW LAWYER IN CALIFORNIA.
SO WHEN I WAS APPOINTED TO THE
FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING.
COMMISSION FIRST IT WAS-EXCELLENT COMMISSION IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE AND THEN TO THE
COUNCIL IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN IN REAPPOINTED IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN MY
PROFESSIONAL LIFE TRULY DID COME
FULL CIRCLE.
AND SINCE THEN I HAVE SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF MY CAREER I HAVE
HER SINCE I LEFT THE DEPARTMENT
FOR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING.
I'VE BEEN REPRESENTING UNION
MEMBERS AND OTHER EMPLOYEES.
EXCEPT FOR THE FIVE YEARS THAT I
TOOK OFF TO BE AN ENGLISH
TEACHER HIGH SCHOOL ENGLISH
TEACHER -- I'VE LEARNED SO MUCH
DURING MY PUBLIC SERVICE ON THE
COUNCIL AND I FEEL THAT I HAVE
MUCH MORE TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
REGULATORY PROCESS.
AMONG THE LESSONS I'VE LEARNED
IS THAT FOR REGULATIONS TO BE
MEANINGFUL.
THEY MUST STRICTLY IT HERE TO
LEGISLATIVE INTENT THAT YOUR
INTENT.
THEY MUST CLARIFY RATHER THAN
OBFUSCATE THE LAW.
THEY MUST USE WORDS THAT ARE
COMPREHENSIBLE.
AND THEY MUST BE WORKABLE.
THAT IS THEY MUST PROVIDE
PRAGMATIC GUIDANCE TO ALL
STAKEHOLDERS.
OTHERWISE REGULATIONS.
WON'T HELP ANYONE INCLUDING
THOSE WHO THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
PROTECT.
SO DURING MY TENURE WITH THE
COUNCIL -- THESE LAST SIX OR
SEVEN YEARS.
I'VE APPLIED THESE PER
IMPERATIVES -- WHEN WORKING ON
REGULATIONS REGARDING DISABILITY
NATIONAL ORIGIN AND TRANS GENDER
EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY RIGHT SACKED?
HARASSMENT TRAINING AND OTHER
ASPECTS OF EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION LAW.
AND MOVING FORWARD I'M EAGER TO
HELP.
COMPLETE A MEANINGFUL SET OF
REGULATIONS TO IMPLEMENT
GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION.
ONE ONE ONE THREE FIVE WHICH IS
THE STATUTORY SCHEME.
THAT -- PROHIBITS DISCRIMINATION
AND PROGRAMS AND ACTIVITIES THAT
RECEIVE STATE FUNDING -- AND I
ALSO -- EXPECT TO ORGANIZE --
HELP ORGANIZE PUBLIC HEARINGS ON
HATE VIOLENCE AROUND THE STATE
AS PART OF THAT SUBCOMMITTEE. TO
DO THIS JOB AND IT IS A JOB
ALBEIT NOT WELL PAYING -- I
BRING NOT ONLY MANY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE AS A PRACTICING
ATTORNEY AND AS A COUNCIL MEMBER
BUT I ALSO BRING WITH ME THE
EXPERIENCE OF BEING AN EMPLOYER
MYSELF.
AS A PARTNER IN A LAW FIRM
WITHIN YOU WITH THE UNIONIZED
WORKFORCE -- AND SO I EIGHT YOU
HAVE I HAVE A BALANCE OF
PERSPECTIVES.
I'M HARD WORKING I LISTEN WELL
I'M RECEPTIVE TO FEEDBACK AND
I'M DEDICATED TO OF HOLDING THE
PUBLIC POLICIES TO PUT INTO
PLACE.
AND I HOPE TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
THIS GREAT STATE.
I'M FROM MISSOURI BUT I AM SO
GLAD TO CALL CALIFORNIA HOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SURE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM PROTECT I'M
SENATORS.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU I'M DEREK
SURE WITH ME TODAY IN AUDIENCES
MY SPOUSE ME A GREAT SHE
PICTURED HER SUPPORT ALL THESE
YEARS.
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON CIVIL
RIGHTS ISSUES AS A LAWYER FOR
OVER FORTY YEARS PRIMARILY ON
HOUSING AND DISABILITY ALONG
WITH SOME EMPLOYMENT.
HI IT'S BEEN AN ABSOLUTE HONOR
TO SERVE ON THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING COUNCIL FOR THE LAST
FOUR YEARS THIS IS MY THIRD
APPOINTMENT.
SAYS I APPRECIATED VERY MUCH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO USE THE SKILLS I
HAVE AND HOUSING AND DISABILITY
IN PARTICULAR TO ADDRESS ISSUES
THAT ARE.
CLEARLY A FUNDAMENTAL IMPORTANCE
TO THE STATE AT THIS POINT IN
TIME.
I'VE LEARNED A GREAT DEAL FOR MY
COLLEAGUES AND THE BROAD CROSS
SECTION OF STAKEHOLDERS WHO --
INFORMER PROCESS AND FROM THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO ATTEND OUR
PUBLIC HEARINGS.
I AM PLEASED TO DURING MY LAST
TERM THE COUNCIL APPROVED.
THE FIRST EVER SET OF HOUSING
REGULATIONS IN FIFTY YEARS
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A SET OF
REGULATIONS UNDER THE FAIR
HOUSING COMPONENTS OF FEE HAVE
BEFORE.
THAT ARE CURRENTLY AWAITING
FINAL APPROVAL AT THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW.
IN IN THE NEXT TERM I LOOK
FORWARD TO DRESSING OTHER FOR
HOUSING HATE CRIME AND OTHER
ISSUES AND PARTICULARLY. TO
UPDATING THE THIRTY FIVE YEAR
OLD REGULATIONS INTERPRETING
GOVERNMENT CUT ONE ONE THREE
FIVE WHICH HIS BROTHER GAVE AS
RECENTLY MSSAGING.
THEY WERE RECENTLY TRANSFERRED
TO A COUPLE YEARS AGO
TRANSFERRED TO THE COUNCIL'S.
A JURISDICTION TO DO WELL MAKING
SO WHAT TO DO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
STRICTLY.
GOOD AFTERNOON PRESIDENT PRO TEM
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
TO MAKE LACE YES I'M A FORMER
JESUIT.
AND A PROFESSOR OF LAW AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
SCHOOL OF LAW.
I LIVE IN OAKLAND WITH MY SPOUSE
INGGRIS SUNNY -- WHERE WE HAVE
RAISED OUR TWO CHILDREN?
I AM VERY HAPPY TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH YOU
TODAY.
I'M HONORED TO BE REAPPOINTED TO
THIS COUNCIL AND I'M VERY
EXCITED TO SERVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA I
FEEL THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
AREA OF PUBLIC POLICY.
AS YOU KNOW HAVING A JOB HAVING
A DECENT STABLE HOUSING IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT BOTH FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL TO BE A PRODUCTIVE
ENGAGED CITIZEN. FOR FAMILIES TO
FUNCTION WELL AND FOR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND CITIES TO BE
HEALTHY.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIA HAS A FAIR
OPPORTUNITY TO GET A JOB TO GET
DECENT HOUSING AND HAVE EQUAL
ACCESS TO PUBLIC ACCOMMODATIONS.
AND IT'S EQUALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE ASSIST INDIVIDUALS AND
BUSINESSES TO COMPLY WITH THE
LAW.
I HAVE ENJOYED BEING ON THE
COUNCIL I THINK THAT I HAVE SOME
RELEVANT.
EXPERIENCE AND EXPERTISE THAT
I'M ABLE TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
COUNCIL'S WORK MY PRIMARILY MY
SCHOLARLY WORK HAS BEEN AND
HOUSING LAW AND HOUSING POLICY.
MY PRIMARY GOAL DURING THE NEXT
TWO YEARS IS TO HELP DRAFT
HOUSING REGULATIONS AND THEN TO
CONTRIBUTE ON OTHER REGULATIONS
THAT ARE BEFORE THE COUNCIL.
THANKS AGAIN FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH YOU I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU EACH OF YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR ROSS LET ME BEGIN WITH
YOU THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM
COUNCILMEMBERS CONGRATULATIONS.
I CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO
MOVING YOUR CONFIRMATIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
I REALLY HAVE NO QUESTIONS BUT I
HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT I WAS --
AMAZED AT THE FACT THAT THE WORK
YOU DO THE VERY IMPORTANT WORK
TO DO IN THE STATE.
YOU LARGELY DO YOURSELVES
WITHOUT A LOT OF STAFF SUPPORT.
OF THAT IS CERTAINLY PUBLIC
SERVICE.
AT ITS HIGHEST LEVEL AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU. FOR WHAT YOU DO
AND WHAT YOU UNDOUBTEDLY WILL
CONTINUE TO DO FOR ALL THE REST
OF US IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SO CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN THANK
YOU MATTER PROTECTING.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH MISTER
VICE CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM I JUST
WANT TO ECHO MIKE MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS WE'RE WALKING THROUGH
THE SUBCOMMITTEES IN YOU DO IT
ALL YOURSELF AND THEN YOU GET
FEEDBACK IN THE DO IT ALL
YOURSELF I'VE NEVER HEARD OF
THAT BEFORE -- I LIKE SENATE
ROTH I DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS --
EITHER AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR APPOINTMENT AND GOD SPEED
WITH YOUR EFFORTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN
SENATOR BATES -- LET ME ECHO
THOSE COMMENTS AND THANKING YOU
FOR THE PASSION AND COMMITMENT
YOU BRING TO YOUR YOUR WORK --
AND WHEN YOU DO IT ALL YOURSELF
CYCLE.
YOU KNOW ABOUT THE THAT HAS TO
BE RELEASED A VERY STRONG VALUE
THAT YOU ALL SHARE.
OF NOW I AM GOING TO ABSTAIN ON
YOUR CONFIRMATION A SPECIFICALLY
BECAUSE A FEW ISSUES TO RAISE
THAT I DON'T BELIEVE OUR CURRENT.
BUT BECAUSE I WAS ABSENT
YESTERDAY AND WAS NOT ABLE.
TO YOU KNOW DO ONE ON ONE WITH
YOU -- I NEED TO CLARIFY THAT IT
HAS TO DO WITH WHETHER YOUR
INTERPRETATION OF THE REGULATION
REALLY GOES TO WHAT MISS ROTH
KEY SAID ABOUT.
REFLECTING WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTENT TWICE SO I
INTEND TO DO JUST A LITTLE
CLOSER LOOK AT THAT.
ON BECAUSE THAT WAS SOMETHING
BROUGHT UP ACTUALLY ON IS REALLY
TWO YEARS AGO HI AND STILL KIND
OF FLOATS OUT THERE WHEN.
I WASN'T REALLY YOU KNOW.
INVOLVED IN ALL THEY ALSO KNOW
THAT I HAVE HIGH REGARD FOR WHAT
YOU DO AND YOUR COMMITMENT TO
YOUR JOB AND JOB.
WHEN WE GET TO THE FLOOR I'LL
HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING AT
THAT TIME?
BUT AGAIN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES SENATOR
MINE THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM.
I ALSO WANT TO ADD MY
CONGRATULATIONS MORE IMPORTANTLY.
MY THANKS FOR YEAR.
TREMENDOUS LEVEL OF SERVICE TO
OUR STATE.
AND I DO HAVE JUST A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS BECAUSE I THINK IT
WILL HELP.
EDUCATE ALL OF THIS IN. TO THOSE%
IN THE PUBLIC THAT MAY BE
LISTING.
AND I'D START WITH MS BROWN SKIN.
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT MACHINE I
HAVE A HISTORY THAT GOES BACK TO
OUR LAW SCHOOL DAYS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN FRANCISCO WERE
MISTER GLACIS NOW SERVES AS A
PROFESSOR -- SO IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU AND TO SEE THE AMAZING
CAREER THAT THAT YOU'VE BUILT.
ON BUT I THINK LURKING AROUND
SOME OF CONCERNS PUBLIC
PERCEPTION WHATEVER.
HELP ME UNDERSTAND HOW YOU SEE
HOW YOU FIND BALANCE BETWEEN
EMPLOYER AND EMPLOYEE INTERESTS
LAWS DESIGNED TO PROTECT
EMPLOYEE RIGHTS BUT FOR THEM TO
BE EFFECTIVE.
YOU NEED TO IN INCLUDING JOHN
EMPLOYER INTERESTS LANDLORD
TENANT.
HOW DO YOU IN YOUR WORK OW DO
YOU -- INCORPORATE THOSE
INTERESTS.
TO A SURE THAT REGULATIONS ARE
CLEAR SHE SAID IN CAN BE
FOLLOWED AND PROVIDE DIRECTION
TO BOTH EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES.
WELL I THINK -- ANNA SPEAKING
FOR MYSELF BUT I THINK I SPEAK
FOR EVERYONE ELSE ON THE COUNCIL
TO IS IT WE PLACED SO CLOSE
ATTENTION TO THE PUBLIC COMMENTS
THAT COME IN.
AND WHAT FROM WHICHEVER SIDE I
MEAN AND THERE ARE SIDES
[inaudible]
EVERYONE -- EVERYONE IS I
CONSIDER EVERYONE I LOOK AT IT I
PUT MYSELF IN THEIR SHOES I LOOK
AT WHETHER IT CAN BE.
WHETHER WHETHER WHAT WE'RE DOING
IS ENFORCEABLE IS IT
COMPREHENSIBLE AS I SAID BEFORE
IS THAT WORKABLE.
AND EIGHT YOU KNOW IT IT AS A
LAWYER WERE TRAINED TO LOOK AT
THE OTHER SIDE ALL THE TIME
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO KNOW WHAT
THE WEAKNESSES OF YOUR CASE IS.
OUR JUSTICE AND YOU NEED TO KNOW
WHAT THE STRENGTHS ARE.
AND SO YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT ALL
SIDES AND FIGURE OUT WHETHER
THAT WORKS AND VERY RARELY DOES
A FIRST DRAFT I MEAN NEVER HAS A
FIRST DRAFT ENDED UP AS A FIRST
DRAFT IN THE WE GO THROUGH SO
MANY VERSIONS OF THESE
REGULATIONS AND IT'S BECAUSE WE
KEEP.
GETTING REPEATEDLY -- PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
FINALLY THE PUBLIC COMMENTS WILL
SAY OKAY YES WE CAN LIVE WITH
THAT OR YOU KNOW SOMETIMES THEY
CAN'T AND WE MAKE WE DO MAKE A
DECISION AT THE END.
BUT WE ALWAYS TRY TO STAY
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WE DO
BELIEVE THE LEGISLATURE INTENDED.
AND WE HAVE A YOU KNOW WE HAVE
AN AMAZING SET OF CIVIL RIGHTS
LAWS IN THIS IN THE STATE AND I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE HAS
DECLARED.
A IT'S PUBLIC POLICY AND WE
ALWAYS TRY TO TRY TO ALWAYS SIT
HERE TO THAT.
THANK YOU IN.
MAYBE WHILE YOU HAVE THE MIKE
JUST A FOLLOW UP FOR FRIEDMAN
SPREAD SKI IS -- AN ESTIMATE OF
HOW MANY HOURS A MONTH YOU MIGHT
DEVOTE TO THIS WORK IT'S LARGELY
VOLUNTARY AND IF YOU HAD A MAGIC
WAND WHAT.
WHAT?
COULD WE DO.
TO OFFER MORE SUPPORT IN THE
SUCCESS OF YOUR MISSION.
WELL IT IT IT ABSENT FLOWS --
WHEN I WHEN I WAS WHEN -- SURE
AND I WERE WORKING ON THE ONE
ONE ONE THREE FIVE A FIRST DRAFT
OF THOSE REGULATIONS WHICH WILL
BE GOING AWAY ALL I WOULD SAY I
SPENT.
I MEAN I DON'T EVEN CAN'T EVEN
ESTIMATE MAYBE. THIRTY HOURS A
WEEK TWENTY HOURS A WEEK I MEAN
A HUGE AMOUNT OF HOURS IN
ADDITION.
TO MY DAY JOB.
AND THEN YOU KNOW PARENTING AND
THINGS OF THAT SORT -- SO IT IT
VERY SOME RIGHT NOW WE'RE
WAITING WE'RE WAITING FOR A
WHALE -- TO HEAR BACK FROM THEM
ON THE REGULATIONS SO THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT OF YOU KNOW THERE IS
DOWN TIME.
SO IT'S NOT CONSTANT BUT WHEN
YOU ARE WORKING ON THESE THINGS
WE SPEND.
WE SPEND ALL I MEAN WE DO ALL
THE RESEARCH THE READNG OF THE
EVERY COMMENT ALL OF THAT SO IT
IT TAKES AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
TIME.
THE DEPARTMENT PROVIDES AN
AMAZING STAFF -- THEY HAVE THEY
ARE THEY ARE AMAZING.
BUT THERE'S NOT ENOUGH.
AND IT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL IF
THERE WAS A LITTLE MORE.
THAT'S BUT DATE THEY DO WHAT
THEY CAN AND I'M I'M SO GRATEFUL
TO HAVE THE DEPARTMENT -- IN
INDIA PH AND WHAT IT DOES FOR US.
BUT IT WOULD BE NICE TO HAVE.
A LITTLE MORE HELP TO AGAIN
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SERVICE -- AND ALE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW YES.
I SHIPS -- TRANSCRIPT A REVIEW
THE THE REGULATIONS BEFORE THEY
THEN.
THANK YOU AND MAKE SURE IF YOU
WANT TO ADD ANYTHING TO THAT
MAYBE BACK TO KIND OF THE CORE
QUESTION OF HOW YOU.
HOW YOU?
LISTEN TO TAKEINTO ACCOUNT THE
CONCERNS OF EMPLOYERS LANDLORDS
AT CITRUS SO THAT WHAT YOU DO
PRODUCE IS.
SOMETHING THAT IS CLEAR AND
PROVIDES GUIDANCE.
I WANT TO ECHO EVERYTHING MISS
BRODSKY SAID -- AS A LITIGATOR
FOR MANY YEARS THANK YOU FOR
FRUSTRATED WHEN I CAN'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT A REGULATION
SAYS SO ONE OF MY GOALS IS TO
TRY AND MAKE SURE.
IT'S VERY HARD TARGET TO HIT
THAT IT'S AS CLEAR AND AS SIMPLE
AS POSSIBLE AND I THINK I SPEAK
FOR ALL OF US WE SAY THAT IS
PART OF THE GOAL THAT WE PAY
CLOSE ATTENTION.
TO WE LISTEN VERY CAREFULLY WE
MAKE CHANGES BASED ON COMMENTS
FROM.
EVERY STAKEHOLDER AND I MUST SAY
IN MANY CASES IT IS NOT TWO
SIDES IT IS THREE OR FOUR OR
FIVE DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES ON
AN ISSUE AND ULTIMATELY THERE IS
A BALANCING TEST BUT WE LEARNED
A LOT FROM ALL OF THEM AND
INITIAL QUESTION THE FIRST STAFF
WE GO A WHOLE.
I DIDN'T REALIZE THAT -- I
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THAT ISSUE SO
THAT'S VERY COMMON.
I WOULD SAY.
I BRING NOT ONLY MAKES FRANCIS
LITIGATOR BUT I'M ALSO A
LANDLORD AND I WORKED ON THE
MANAGEMENT SIDE AS A MANAGER IN
MY AGENCY FOR MANY YEARS SO.
I'VE ALSO HAD SOME ABILITY TO
SEE MOST OF THESE THINGS FROM
BOTH SIDES.
RELEASE OR TALK ABOUT HOUSING
AND EMPLOYMENT REGULATIONS --
ULTIMATELY IT IS TRYING TO DO
WHAT WE UNDERSTAND THE
LEGISLATURE TO HAVE DIRECTED IN
TERMS OF A STRONG COMMITMENT TO
CIVIL RIGHTS THAT IS.
FAIR TO EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU IN.
I WAS ABLE TO MEET WITH MISS
BRIDE'S GAME MISTER GLACIS WE
WERE CUT SHARK SAID TO GO
PRESENT A BILL BUT I DO WANT T
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE SAN.
THANK YOUR SPOUSE FOR SUPPORT
AND ALL OF YOU YOUR SPOUSE'S FOR
THEIR SUPPORT IN A SENSE I CAN
PULL YOURS FOR THEIR SUPPORT.
AS WELL -- I KNOW YOU DON'T DO
THIS ALONE SO THANK YOU IN JUST
A FINAL QUESTION FIVE MIGHT FOR
MISTER GLACIS.
I KNOW THE THE COUNCIL CONVENE
THE PUBLIC HEARING IN FRESNO AND
THEN.
YOU TOOK SOME OF THE INITIATIVE
ON THAT AGAIN MAYBE WITHOUT A
WHOLE LOT OF STAFF SUPPORT BUT
WHAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THAT HOW
DOES THAT HELP IN.
FULFILLING YOUR MISSION AND TO
HAVE OTHER PLANS.
FOR PUBLIC MEETINGS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YES SO -- WE
CONVENED A PUBLIC HEARING TO
HEAR FROM COMMUNITY GROUPS AND
INDIVIDUALS IN THE A CENTRAL
VALLEY FOR ANY CIVIL RIGHTS
ISSUES THAT.
ARE WITHIN OUR JURISDICTION THAT
THEY WANTED TO SHARE WITH US IT
WILL LARGELY THEIR PURPOSE WAS
BOTH TO HEAR THEM TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE BEING ATTENTIVE TO
THOSE ISSUES BUT ALSO.
TO SEE IF THERE ARE PARTICULAR
REGULATIONS ARE THINGS THAT WE
OUGHT TO CHANGE IN REFERENCE TO
THEIR CONCERNS.
THAT YOU KNOW WE HAD A TAKE ON
AS AN AGENDA -- IT WAS A VERY
WELL ATTENDED MEETING AND I
THINK THAT PEOPLE -- IN CENTRAL
VALLEY WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE
OF OF SORT OF BEING HEARD IN
BEING TAKEN SERIOUSLY IN AND WE
ARE.
PLANNING AT ANOTHER HEARING ON
HATE VIOLENCE PROBABLY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA MAYBE
RIVERSIDE AREA -- AGAIN FOR THE
SAME PURPOSE SO IT BECAUSE IT
IT'S WITHIN THE COUNCILS --
AUTHORITY TO NOT ONLY DRAFT
REGULATIONS BUT ALSO TO HOLD
SUCH HEARINGS.
TO MAKE AN ISSUE REPORTS AS WELL
AS TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS BOTH
TO THE LEGISLATURE AND TO THE
GOVERNOR SO -- WE'RE TRYING TO
COLONEL WE'VE BEEN MOSTLY
FOCUSED ON REGULATION BUT WE'RE
TRYING TO ALSO FULFILL THOSE
OTHER RESPONSIBILITIES THANK YOU
SO MUCH OF MY FINAL QUESTION
JUST IT'S IN YOUR CV BUT YOU'RE
A FULL TIME PROFESSOR AT USF
SCHOOL OF LAW.
MAY BE SURE WHAT YOUR FIELD OF
EXPERTISE HIS BECAUSE I THINK IT
HELPS INFORM THE WORK YOU DO ON
THE COUNCIL AS WELL.
THANK YOU SO SO I TEACH PROPERTY
LAW WHICH HAS A HOUSING
COMPONENT IN THE NINETIES.
A COMMUNITY PROPERTY WHICH IS
CALIFORNIA'S MERYL POPULI TEACH
A COURSE ON A FICTION LAWYERING.
ALSO TEACH A COURSE CALLED
CONTEMPLATIVE LORING WHERE WE
TEACH LAST INTO MEDITATE INNER
HOW TO MANAGE STRESS AND BE
BETTER LAWYERS BUT MY
SCHOLARSHIP HAS BEEN ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY FOCUSED ON HOUSING --
EITHER BOTH HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
AND FAIR HOUSING LAW.
THANK YOU AND HAVE YOU DEVELOPED
A MEDIATION COMPONENT FOR
LEGISLATORS.
DID I SEE MEDIATION I'M AND
MEDITATE.
I'M THE MEDIATOR WE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR SERVICE.
I THANK YOU SENATOR MINING --
RIGHT YOU READ MY MIND -- I I MS
BRODSKY I JUST HAVE TO ASK.
YOU WERE A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER
IN BETWEEN BEING AN ATTORNEY
HIGH SCHOOL AND A TURKEY I GOT A
NOW ALL RIGHT.
I'VE PRACTICED OVER THIRTEEN
YEARS BUT I ALWAYS HAD THIS MAD
CRAVING TO BE AN ENGLISH
PROFESSOR BUT AT THAT POINT I
WAS TOO OLD TO GO BACK AND GET A
PHD SO I THOUGHT I WANT TO BE AN
ENGLISH HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER SO I
WENT BACK AND TAUGHT HIGH.
SCHOOL FOR FIVE GOT MY
CREDENTIALS [inaudible] FIVE
YEARS.
I I AND THEN I WENT BACK TO LAW.
AND NOW I REPRESENT A LOT OF
EDUCATORS THAT'S MY MY SORT OF
SPECIALIZED AREA.
WELL I APPRECIATE YOU ANSWERING
THE UNRELATED QUESTION.
THIS JOB I EVER HAD I THINK THE
WAY.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN TEACHER FOR A DAY IT'S
NOT REALLY TEACHER FOR DAY IT'S
TEACHER FOR THE TWENTY MINUTES
THEY LET YOU DO IT.
WITH A GROUP OF SECOND GRADERS
YOU COME AWAY WITH A WHOLE
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE -- ID --
YOU KNOW CLEARLY EACH OF YOU
HAVE SERVED.
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS ACTUALLY
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE VERY HIGH
PAY THAT YOU WERE GIVEN.
I AND FOR THE PUBLIC IT'S AND
IT'S A HUNDRED DOLLARS TYPE IN
PER DAY -- AND AFTER HERE AND
HOW MANY HOURS A WEEK YOU PUT
INTO THIS AND THE COMPLEXITY AND
THE FACT THAT YOU ARE WILLING TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE.
OUR TO PROVIDE YOUR EXPERTISE
WHICH IS CLEARLY OUTLINED IN
YOUR RESUMES PROVIDED -- I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU -- I THINK
IT'S VERY HARD WORK I THINK IT'S
COMPLEX -- AND WE APPRECIATED I
APPRECIATED IS REALLY TO BE
COMMENDED SO.
I REALLY DON'T HAVE OTHER
QUESTIONS ALTHOUGH IF YOU WANT
ME I'LL COME UP WITH A FEW --
BUT I WANT TO INVITE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT -- TO STEP FORWARD --
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR NAME WHO YOU
REPRESENT AND BRIEF COMMENTS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
ALEXANDER HER NAME WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY HERE AND STRONG SUPPORT --
I JUST REALLY APPRECIATE ALL OF
THE WORK THAT THAT THIS COUNCIL
HAS DONE THE REGULATIONS ARE
THOUGHTFUL THEIR CLEAR THEY'RE
VERY UNDERSTANDABLE -- AND I
APPRECIATE THAT BOTH AS A FORMER
LEGAL AID ATTORNEY AND NOW IS
SOMEBODY WHO PROVIDE SUPPORT TO
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS -- THEY HAVE
ONE OF THE MOST DELIBERATIVE AND
SORT OF A GENUINE PUBLIC COMMENT
PROCESSES THAT THAT I HAVE SEEN
OF ANYBODY'S SO.
THANK YOU AND WE SUPPORT THE
CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WELCOME BACK MY NUMBER MADAM
CHAIR ABOVE AND SLAVERY TO
PROTOCOL MY CAR WITH THE WESTERN
SERRA Là POVERTY AND I ONLY GET
UP BECAUSE I WANT -- TO
PERSONALLY SUPPORT THIS
PROFESSOR GLACIS AND MR WERE
I'VE KNOWN THE BALL FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS I'VE HIGH
ADMIRATION FOR THEIR SKILL LEVEL
AND DEDICATION. TO LAW AND I
EIGHT THINK THEY'RE JUST GONNA
BE OUTSTANDING APPOINTMENTS
TODAY AT THE AGE AND FULLY
SUPPORT THEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS BATES.
MONNING MONNING AYE ROTH ROTH I
WILL CLIMB WILK AYE ATKINS HI.
THAT CARRIES A WITH A OF FOUR
YES AND ZERO FOUR ZERO THANK YOU.
GRADUATION [inaudible]
THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE -- I PLEDGE
THANK YOU
.
WE ARE GOING TO ADJOURN INTO
EXECUTIVE SESSION.
AS THE ROOM CLEARS